that the fact people have to go on
strike to get [__] paid it's crazy
when they're already out here all the
time you spend volunteering as actors to
even get work and then you have to go on
strike and be in a union um what was the
thing that it said with deer deck a
bunch of people went to um what was that
uh I don't know did you see that no what
happened about Ridiculousness they
changed the amount of
episodes um they're always trying to
really screw over the people
in like they can't fight back
yes like if you're like an extra and you
were like in Batman and you were the hot
dog guy you can't yeah you can't afford
the attorneys that are going to battle
them you can't fight back so they're
basically like we've just we've just
aied you you're the hot dog guy and
everything now and then it's like hell
cuz you're the famous hot dog guy people
come back from the movie theater and
they go that's my dad yeah but then they
have no money have no way to contact
and he's he's living in the desert and
it's terrible and like people just see
see him all the time they go and he's
got like you know he's got maybe
diabetes or something and he's just
sitting there and they're going you're
the guy that always serves the hot dog
to every superhero he has no money no
way to even get H he's put he'll
literally put just sit there all day and
put mustard on his finger and just
licking mustard in the middle of the
desert in the Salt Flats of the
California Nevada desert living there
and they go this guy is a hot dog guy
and they act like died he doesn't even
die and they have like an in memorium to
him Academy Award because they don't
want to pay him anymore they want to pay
him so they just say he died they get
him off and he's screaming in a
Greyhound bus station goes I'm alive you
[__] I'm alive Ridiculousness writers
stormed Rob jer's office asking for a
meeting but he was nowhere to be found
so they straight up tried to get him yep
on January 4th the writers of
ridiculousness asked host and executive
producer Rob jck for his support for a
fair contract wow wow they just want a
fair contract to apparently around 10 of
the show's writers storm deer's office
but were turned away when they called
and left messages no one answered cuz
you know what it is they looked at
January 6 and they go that got some
results like that woke people up a
little bit that got some heat you know
that got some heat you know rightly or
wrongly it got some heat so I think a
lot of these writers were like let's
just storm his office right now yeah and
try to
like they asked host deer deck for
support for a fair contct name Ryan
Conor uh I am here my fellow writers at
because we just wanted to ask him for
his support in our efforts to get our
first he was a comic New York City wow
tried to go up
um or whatever oh gosh gosh sorry that's
okay um we called we left a message
nobody answered hi uh this is the
writers from Ridiculousness we are here
in the uh ground floor of the building
just to ask if we could talk to Rob so
it looks like they're trying to go there
and and get a hold of him and they can't
is that the gist of it Nick is that's a
gist and you know that guy Ryan Connor
yeah he was a nice guy he was a comic in
New York City and I guess he moved out
here I guess became a writer wow and
what did that article say towards the
end Nick do you
mind um oh it said uh we are currently
compensated at a rate well below our
peers no well below our peers writing
for wga coverage shows like
Ridiculousness the next step is they're
gonna have to kidnap him well and
they're going to call and they're going
to go we have him like we have Rob Deer
deck and what do you want and yeah and
I'm not saying that I condone that sort
of no of course not but I'm saying like
the next step logically logically is to
kidnap robbed your deck and they're
gonna go hi and you could do it like
just the way he did it you can be like
hey um this Ryan Connor and uh I I just
want to say we have robbed your deck oh
it's just like we tried it the first way
yeah we tried it your way we went to the
lobby remember that it's Terminator and
he's going to box you his box few times
like like make some sounds it's me they
got me andone goes yeah yeah yeah get by
a skape
yeah yeah yeah he goes he goes we got
rubbed your deck here he's unharmed I
hit the Box ah hear him he's unharmed
but we are just trying to get a fair
contract so let's start the negotiation
yeah let's start it now let's just start
it now because we have Rob and an
undisclosed location but that's the next
logical step here you have to
kidnap uh Comm deer you have to Common
deer Rob Deer deck yes for a few days
yes for a few days to just get
people awake awake because this doesn't
by the way I see that I see people in
the lobby of a building I go all right
yeah so what you know but you got to pay
these people you got to pay them money
what does it say about the episodes Nick
they used to do 30 in 2011 when they
started and now they're doing 336 wow a
year and they're not
Union wow well they got to put him in a
box yeah I mean or they could do the old
school move
you ever see marcha Wooden Soldiers uhuh
Laur and Hardy fat guy thin guy
brilliant they mail themselves in a box
the old school move yeah to Rob Troy Rob
de exactly Trojan Horse Trojan Horse Rob
Deer deck they're like he goes oh
someone sent something like the studio
sent something nice to the house they
got a big
box it opens and it's the whole writing
staff yeah right there there it is
standing olly it's the whole writing
staff and then all a
sudden then but then they still here's
what's interesting about that they
actually still have to kidnap him right
so it's like forget the Box because they
still have but they still mean business
it's a way to get in the building it's a
way to get in the building but they they
have to just say hi my name is Ryan
Connor I'm a writer at Ridiculousness
and we have Rob yeah we tried it your
way yeah and but Rob is here and Rob is
now very enthusiastic about this new
contract AR you rob hit the cage Rob
Rob is had a change of heart he's
actually leading the
charge for this new contract right in
the cage yes yes give him give him
anything they want we're not even asking
for that Rob but thank you for saying
that I believe we have them that's that
quote Yeah that's quot she just heard
was give them anything they want please
I just want to leave here alive he's
being fed we're taking care of him no
one's abusing him you think if I don't
even think they pay people to I think
they offered me to go on that show
before and they don't even pay you to go
it's not good if they're not paying they
don't even pay you to go be a guest on
that show yeah like they say oh will you
get publicity out of it that's what they
always say about everything we're paying
you an exposure right but yeah these
people are exposed they they don't have
health care that's the problem people
are exposed are in the elements yeah you
think you think writing 330 6 episodes
of this
show what even is this show they get
like Snookie and someone else to they
get snook in then they Commander some
brother out there right and uh just like
you know it's usually like somebody that
knocked up a Kardashian or something or
at least came near one and they get them
to um right to do to to to literally
look at videos of people who are
breaking their necks doing different
stunts gotcha and they make and make fun
of them they say that right okay well
again I Chelle West Coast is onest she's
actually really funny yeah she's really
funny I just you know I'm I'm never a
person for extremes but I do believe in
this rare instance it just bargaining
power being what it is it it just if you
have them it makes it a lot easier yeah
yeah I agree just throwing it out if you
have them if you have them un just like
like think about the movie Seven mhm
great movie Seven MH great movie now the
reason that everybody was so uh wound up
in seven is because
there there was a serial killer who just
kept like leaving little notes you know
communicating with the cops making phone
calls yeah gossipy kind of guy gossipy
kind of guy but he didn't show up in the
um you know like the office building you
know what I mean what he was able to do
is really capture people's attention
by by actually going like hey I got the
I I'm I'm I got the thing I got the guy
so the reality is what they need to do
is just in a nice way uh kidnap him yeah
I think common Dearing is the term we
like to use that's correct command
Deering someone command Deering someone
yeah for the purposes of a nego contract
negotiation is great yeah well look it's
getting to that point and I won't be
because at one point all it's GNA take
is the policeman to say wait I'm not on
the side of this company no the police
I'm on the side of this person here's
the brilliant thing about this the
police might help this yeah the police
actually the police
might they might not look too hard for
him right they might not be looking too
hard for him okay because the show I
believe is celebrating accidents right
yeah celebrating just public lawlessness
yeah the cops aren't looking too hard
for this guy and plus here's thing if
they're not paying people for the clips
that I'm using I'm sure they're not and
they're not paying guests to go on there
and I it's probably like some guy in
like a on a stretcher and they just like
a producer runs up to them and they go
do you mind if we use this on
ridiculousness and the GU like and
they're like great counts yeah will you
put a little your salive on this
contract right yeah um but I and I
remember them offering and they did not
offer a payment on it but then who's
making all the money then probably the
network I mean the show the these days
it's only ridiculous it's their own what
was the deal they had and I'm all for
people making money yeah and I'm not
trying to [__] on maybe it's just a
misunderstanding but no and maybe he's
doing the right thing I'm not right
we're not being negative we're just
saying Zoom I'm zooming out I'm zooming
out that this is an overall this I don't
even care who he is who they are I'm
just talking about negotiations in
general agreed one person usually has
all the leverage yeah is my point and if
you yeah and sometimes you have to bring
a true article to the uh to what the
writers did there we had no imagination
right which maybe means they shouldn't
be getting paid maybe they shouldn't be
getting paid I gotta be honest I didn't
see one funny thing happening that's a
good point there was not one funny thing
those writers did but sometimes you got
to bring a real article to the ne they
all dressed up like clowns and they were
like oh you're treating us like clowns
but bloody clowns or big like remember
big that passed away remember Robin big
what if Dred like big like mummified big
like we came back from the and big would
be ashamed of this yes big would be
ashamed of the way we're being treated
kind of like a Christmas story like a
Christmas carol rip big to big they all
so our our thing is telling the writers
to do blackface well I well I'd go sure
but I I'm just saying at this point at
this point you're desperate action
desperate magic I get it now a black
riter you they call Rob Dudu they go
listen listen to this the writers are
mad they're in the lobby of the building
but here's here's where they [__] up
Rob they're all in blackface you're off
the hook you're actually Fu or you don't
have to pay any of them or Hollywood's
so scared of everything they're like we
better pay these black writers right now
that's right that's the truth that's a
good point Hollywood be like the last
thing we want to do is upset the black
community that's right yeah they come in
if I yeah if I were black I would just
Sue everybody in Hollywood that's true
to be honest with you that's a good
point to be honest with you just start
suing every human being in
Hollywood